extranjero
[Música]
bienvenido a la transmisión en vivo activa número
50.0 es el 17 de octubre de 2022 y estamos
comenzando la serie sobre interocepción como
modelado de alostasis como control
bienvenido al Instituto de inferencia activa
somos un Instituto participativo en línea
que está comunicando aprendizaje
y  practicando inferencia activa aplicada
esto se graba en una transmisión en vivo de archivo
, así que envíenos sus
comentarios para que podamos mejorar nuestro trabajo
todos los antecedentes y perspectivas son
bienvenidos y seguiremos una buena
etiqueta de video para transmisiones en vivo
hoy en 50.0 estamos comenzando esta serie
discutiendo  la intercepción del artículo como
modelo de alostasis como control
los autores son Eli synesh Jordan
therialt Dana Brooks John wilheim Von
DeMint Lisa Feldman Barrett y Karen s
Quigley es un artículo publicado en la revista
biología psicología en enero de 2022
y esto es solo una introducción y
contexto  video como Dean aquí y yo
trabajo a través de este documento y discutimos algunos
temas relacionados
que  Voy a repasar algunas
preguntas importantes, los objetivos básicos y el resumen de la
hoja de ruta del artículo, luego entraré en el
artículo, tocaré algunos puntos clave,
imágenes y temas, y luego, principalmente,
espero discutirlo con cualquier
autor o cualquier otra persona que desee.  para
unirme en las próximas semanas, de acuerdo
, soy Daniel, soy un investigador
en California y
el artículo fue seleccionado por
voto
a favor descentralizado, fue muy divertido de leer y trae algunos
temas nuevos a nuestro régimen de atención,
así que estoy buscando  adelante a esto y le
pasaré a Dean
gracias Charlie Soy Dean Estoy aquí en
Calgary
Creo que lo que es interesante acerca de cualquier
papel que tira de cosas aparentemente
discretas
y pone algo proximal y
las enreda y luego las
separa de nuevo  y trata de ver algo de
lo que sucede cuando las cosas se combinan es
algo que siempre me
interesa, de hecho, era el
título de esto y el hecho de que
estaban uniendo la alostasis y la
terescepción y ¿qué?
Esa fue la razón por la que dediqué un
poco de tiempo a esto y realmente
estoy bastante interesado en escuchar lo que los
autores tienen que decir ahora que pusieron
esta idea en práctica
¿cómo describirías la gran
pregunta?  Quiero decir, creo que el enfoque aquí está
en lo que sucede y lo que podemos decir
sobre los requisitos del controlador necesarios
para llevar a cabo tareas fisiológicas con diversos
grados de complejidad.
Nunca he estado realmente seguro de cómo se ve la
especificidad de los diferentes resultados y
comportamientos en conjunto, pero  Creo que
una de las cosas que podemos decir es si
hay un componente predictivo y
hay un componente de retroalimentación
y se están enfocando en dos
tipos particulares de eso.
tipo de no
perderse en la maleza de bueno, esto sucedió
aquí y luego eso sucedió allí, pero
solo en ese nivel general, qué
tipo de cosas cuando esas dos cosas
se juntan
um, ¿deberíamos decir como un cierto patrón o
similitud
agradable? Estoy de acuerdo. Lo pondría en la
categoría de preguntar cómo un sistema dado es
independiente
o fenómenos independientes de la modalidad como la
alostasis, que es cambios anticipatorios
en la fisiología y se conecta con un dominio
o un caso de uso como la intercepción.  y
parece que muchos de los modelos que
hemos explorado han sido visuales,
conceptuales o simbólicos,
y la modalidad interceptiva ha
aparecido una y otra vez en las discusiones, por lo que
esta es una buena oportunidad para ver
algunos formalismos para la interceptación
.  el artículo,
tal como se describió anteriormente, solo algunos de los
puntos destacados que escribieron los
autores en la
página de publicación la
intercepción permite que el cerebro
anticipe las próximas necesidades metabólicas del cuerpo la
intercepción proporciona
métricas de rendimiento para la regulación motora de las vísceras
conectamos la teoría del control con la toma de
decisiones y el control motor  del cuerpo
modelamos el control alostático como un
control óptimo con el tiempo varían  ing
señal de referencia
hablan de algunas
limitaciones de los modelos anteriores y algunos
aspectos únicos de lo que hace su modelo
y la forma en que formulan el modelo apic
cualquier cosa para agregar
no, creo que sus objetivos son
sencillos,
está bien en el reclamo, así que Dean y yo estábamos
pensando en
pensar  de nosotros mismos
en términos de ajustadores de siniestros, tasadores,
examinadores e investigadores,
ya que
extrajimos un puñado de elementos realmente
importantes y destacados
dentro del argumento de este documento relativamente
largo
y técnicamente andamiado
y extrajimos un montón de afirmaciones
escritas que conectan los puntos y
establecen  algunas de las
interpretaciones relevantes para los formalismos
, ¿quieres resaltar alguna de ellas
o está bien tenerlas
para cualquiera que quiera
dejar de lado esto, pero diré esto aquí
, creo que hay un paralelo tratando de
dibujarse?  aquí entre
predictivo
predictivo uh procesamiento no, no estoy
diciendo que el procesamiento predictivo sino el
procesamiento como un dispositivo predictivo
y sentimientos
y control y retroalimentación, así que creo que
hay muchas afirmaciones que se pueden
hacer,
pero ese es un espacio
muy, muy matizado y también muy, muy
complejo para jugar, así que puedo
entender por qué,
um, hay montones, montones de  afirmaciones
um otra vez si o no o hasta qué punto esas
afirmaciones pueden sostenerse antes de que se rompan
será algo interesante para hablar
con los autores,
sí, bien dicho, es un área muy entrelazada
, tal vez eso es lo que estás señalando
cuando dices operación compleja,
sí  Tengo mucho cabello, así que es
complicado para mí,
está bien, resumen, está bien, leeré los tres primeros,
el cerebro regula el cuerpo al
anticipar sus necesidades e intentar
satisfacerlas antes de que surjan, un proceso
llamado alostasis, la
alostasis requiere un modelo del
cambiando las condiciones sensoriales dentro del
cuerpo un proceso llamado intercepción en
este artículo examinamos cómo la interocepción
puede proporcionar retroalimentación de rendimiento para la
alostasis
sugerimos estudiar la alostasis en te  rms
de la teoría de control revisando las
aplicaciones de las teorías de control a temas relacionados
en fisiología control motor y toma de
decisiones las
sintetizamos relacionándolas con
las propiedades importantes de la
regulación outostática como un problema de control luego
esbozamos un formalismo normal de cómo el
cerebro podría realizar el control alostático
de  las vísceras, por analogía, dos
controles motores esqueléticos que incluyen una
vista matemática y cómo la intersección actúa como una
retroalimentación del rendimiento para la alostasis.
Finalmente, sugerimos formas de probar las
implicaciones de nuestra hipótesis.
presenta algunos de los
pilares o fundamentos clave de su
síntesis e interpretación,
que es la
teoría del control de la intercepción como un enfoque para
unificar la
toma de decisiones del control motor fisiológico
y la alostasis como un
seguimiento de la trayectoria del control estocástico óptimo
la quinta sección es una discusión y
luego hay un apéndice B y  C
un  y en sus palabras cuatro secciones en este
documento conectan la intercepción con la alostasis la
sección dos establece cómo la
interocepción permite al cerebro
estimar la eficiencia fisiológica
del cuerpo en el momento presente que es
precisamente lo que necesita saber para
evaluar y refinar la acción La
sección 3 introduce el control  La
sección de teoría 4 aplica los principios de la
teoría de control para derivar un
modelo de formato novedoso de cómo el cerebro podría estimar
la conveniencia de las
trayectorias fisiológicas y tomar
decisiones regulatorias prospectivas. Finalmente, la sección 5
sintetiza las tres secciones anteriores
para explorar las implicaciones directas
del formalismo propuesto. Apéndice a.
proporciona un glosario de términos, pero se
movió hacia arriba y ya no es un apéndice,
por lo que no hay un apéndice un
apéndice B1 proporciona
detalles matemáticos relacionados con la sección 3 y el
apéndice C1 proporciona
detalles matemáticos relacionados con la sección 4
.  te vas  hablar mucho sobre la
intercepción y la alostasis
un poco en este punto cero, pero ciertamente
en las próximas discusiones y para el
procesamiento predictivo, una buena
transmisión reciente es la transmisión en vivo número 43 con
María,
está bien, también solo como referencia, haremos una pausa
en esto el tiempo suficiente para usted  para hacer una
captura de pantalla si lo desea,
hay una tabla de nomenclatura
con la definición de muchas palabras, así que
aquí están los primeros términos de la nomenclatura del 1
al 25.
y luego aquí está la segunda mitad de la
nomenclatura del 26 al 49.
ordénelo alfabéticamente
cualquier cosa para agregar a la nomenclatura que
no sea  para decir
que es bueno que lo proporcionaran y
que se usará en las próximas secciones,
bueno, creo que es interesante que hayas
señalado que el um que sacaron
sacaron las definiciones hacia adelante y luego
cuando miras los formalismos y
creo que  desde el punto de vista de
lo que quieren enviar en torno a
esto,
este
trenzado requiere que al menos tengamos un
sentido común sobre lo que significan las cosas
antes  empezamos
a tratar de separar lo que son iguales,
así que sí, en cierto modo,
así lo dije, de acuerdo,
sección uno, introducción, las
funciones del cerebro en el cuerpo,
está bien,
hay un comienzo evocador para este
artículo,
um, jugando un juego simple de dodgeball,
entonces  requiere que su cerebro
coordine continuamente los sistemas de su cuerpo
y este motivo de dodgeball
regresará nuevamente
y a la izquierda hay una cara que abraza la
implementación de un
algoritmo de difusión estable El mensaje de la imagen era
DodgeBall hormigas juguetonas inferencia activa
principio de energía libre
y mientras hacíamos las diapositivas,
estábamos involucrados en una inferencia activa con
algunas de estas
posibilidades de generación de imágenes y permitiéndoles
hacer
lo que bien.
palabra Estoy buscando
enredo de estos de estos avisos
pero no hablé nada sobre qué
estrategia cada uno de  esos,
um, Silhouettes ahora está empleando
y creo que hay una sensación implícita de
que también hay una estrategia en marcha
, así que nuevamente, cuando juntas algunas de
estas cosas realmente interesantes,
um, supongo que depende de qué tan profundo
quieras llegar.  quieres
dimensionalizar el espacio,
así que, ¿qué es eso de ahí
?  siguiente palabra clave, puede optar por ella
si solo las personas pueden leer la
definición aquí, pero solo den su propia
opinión sobre lo que es la intercepción,
bueno, creo que al final del
día hay una cierta cantidad de
señales que están sucediendo de las que nos
damos cuenta  de a veces los jóvenes
o todas las personas les gusta categorizarlos
a todos bajo el paraguas de los sentimientos
y
agarré esto de tots On Target solo
porque siempre trabajé en t  qué tipo de
espacio de cómo mantenemos esto tan simple
como podamos y así cuando recibes estas
señales, estas señales sensoriales se
originan dentro del cuerpo, estos son los
sentimientos que tienes y, ya sea
que los conectes o no con el mundo fuera de
tu
piel o tus márgenes,
um, a veces lo haces, a veces no
, simplemente te despiertas con dolor de barriga,
entonces, ¿qué significa eso sobre el día de hoy?
eso está en el Tarot dentro
del cuerpo a diferencia del Tarot X
fuera del cuerpo, pero probablemente
también haya mucha borrosidad y lo que
realmente está haciendo la retina es
inferir sobre sí misma y dónde está
realmente haciendo inferencia en la estructura del mundo exterior.
Modelos internos interceptivos correctos Agregaste algunas imágenes, entonces,
¿qué
son? Voy a leer esto muy rápido para que los
psicólogos se refieran al mod interno,
incluida la intercepción por muchos términos y
Creo que creo que es importante
porque no siempre ha habido
acuerdo sobre definir claramente qué es un
modelo interno,
cosas como el interés inconsciente
parece encajar en este
paraguas.  No sé lo que
eso significa, eh, e independientemente de cómo
se llame, se supone que el cerebro
construye un modelo dinámico de su cuerpo en
el mundo. En este documento, usamos los términos
predicción, simulación y concepto, y así
para alguien con una especie de experiencia profunda en mi
investigación.  en términos de
abducción, la señal, la interpretación
del objeto,
¿qué es ese modelo?
los datos de una sola vez nos llegan y
se vierten
en nuestras diferentes superficies sensoriales
exterior exterior en el exterior
Creo que hay una pieza que
viene de afuera. Sé cuando
sube la temperatura en la habitación, pero mi
temperatura también podría estar subiendo
porque comí un camarón en mal estado y a
veces es difícil saber
si es porque el calor se
fue.  o si mi cuerpo está respondiendo
con un gesto inflamatorio,
sí, eso es un
buen punto, como a veces llamado una
causa que hace la diferencia o una diferencia
que hace la diferencia, ¿una
infección viral hace que la temperatura corporal
aumente o en qué medida se puede
descomponer en factores de  el virus
versus esto la dinámica cambiando el
sistema inmunológico
tan
interesante imagen de la izquierda sabe que
no puedo decir si la imagen de la izquierda
por la imagen de la izquierda cuál es la
velocidad la imagen de la derecha realmente se está
moviendo por el camino y  Es por
eso que quería la ambigüedad allí
para un modelo de enteroceptor porque
sabes que Demacio habla mucho sobre lo
que realmente podemos
describir y perseguir pr  términos específicos y
lo que sigue siendo algo ambiguo y los
autores en este documento también hablan un poco
sobre Dios, sí, cuando el referente
es externo, es objetivo, entonces existe
la oportunidad de que múltiples perspectivas externas se
alineen, sin siquiera decir
que eso es mejor, sino solo la oportunidad
de mientras que  si se cambia el comportamiento incorporado de
su punto de ajuste fisiológico para alguna
regulación fisiológica
, no tiene la misma
oportunidad para la alineación externa nuevamente
para bien y para mal
y casi siempre con dificultad para
comunicarse o, a veces, medir en
entornos de laboratorio y citar el
control
Entonces  hablar con los autores sobre esto y por
qué estudian esta modalidad
será muy interesante en cuanto a los
fenómenos computacionales o independientes del sistema
que intentarán integrar
con Alice con la intersección es
alostasis. Definen este término como
alostasis es anticipar  las
necesidades cambiantes evalúan las prioridades y preparan
la organización  sm para satisfacerlos antes de que
conduzcan a errores, un proceso llamado
alostasis, así que digamos que
tiene un modelo alostático de la
temperatura en la habitación
y la temperatura corporal central no
cambia, entonces puede uno mirar hacia atrás y decir
que no lo hizo  cambiar porque se esperaba
que cambiara
y alguien dirá, bueno, ¿cómo
sabes que funcionó? Entonces, porque
no elevó la temperatura corporal.
Me concentré en la parte del hecho de que
lo describen como un proceso de tres partes.
siempre hablando de cuál es
el mínimo aquí cuál es el mínimo aquí
lo que necesitamos para poder hacer
esto me parece que realmente no es muy
interesante
por qué tres,
no cuatro o cinco lo están dividiendo
en porciones más pequeñas esa es otra vez
otra de esas  Preguntas Me
gustaría poder hablar con los autores sobre
todas las inferencias activas correctas
que escribieron
antes de
sumergirse en los detalles de modelado formal a
continuación, a los que llegaremos más adelante
en el
documento. Podría ser útil para  compare y
contraste el enfoque aquí
apic
con la inferencia activa del marco de modelado prominente
y vamos a
volver a algunos de estos detalles y estoy
seguro de que tendremos mucha discusión al respecto, pero
usted hizo un punto muy interesante en
nuestra preparación sobre cómo  no están
tratando su modelo como
Downstream o un corolario de ningún
compromiso con una física en particular, que
es la forma en que a menudo escuchamos sobre el
principio de energía libre, básicamente mecánica,
sino que están tratando
el
modelo como una construcción de primer orden,
cualquier cosa que quieras agregar.  eso porque
pensé que realmente me ayudaría a
enmarcar de qué se trataba el documento,
sí, esa es la parte de Street, creo que la
viñeta de trabajo, a diferencia de la mayoría de los
modelos de interés activo en la literatura, es el
material a continuación que considera un
tiempo indefinido o una configuración de control de horizonte infinito
es interesante porque  eso deja
muy muy claro entre lo que están
hablando y lo que a menudo vemos en
muchas de las representaciones, que es t0
T1 a T
lo que sea
en términos de poder averiguar
qué está sucediendo secuencialmente, así que está
bien,
esta sección en la introducción habla
sobre algunos problemas con otros
modelos, habla sobre cómo los modelos existentes de
intercepción han formulado la
alostasis como una decisión prospectiva.
hacer un problema
sin considerar cómo se promulgan estas decisiones,
lo que tiene un montón de
interpretaciones diferentes, pero tal vez, por
ejemplo, requiera la enumeración de
políticas y luego la selección de
políticas
o como un problema de control del motor sin
considerar de dónde provienen los comandos del motor.
otro problema que tienen con otros
los modelos en lugar de tratar la
eficiencia metabólica como el objetivo, discuten la
homeostasis, la regulación de las
variables corporales para fijar puntos fijos con una
tolerancia fija al error, por
lo que este será realmente un
tema interesante que, en
lugar de fijar el punto fijo y la
variabilidad,
ve ese resultado como  debido a algún
otro proceso que da como resultado un
atractivo  un conjunto o punto de actuación con un
punto de ajuste fijo y una tolerancia empírica para el
error, así como quizás algunos puntos sin
retorno, etc.,
pero viendo todos esos resultados como la
realización de un sistema dinámico que en
realidad no persigue un punto de ajuste, sino
más bien  sigue una pendiente en un gráfico
que exploraremos y que, como la zona de
control máximo
y la reducción de la sorpresa alrededor de la
zona de control máximo
durante el tiempo evolutivo, se
asociará con este tipo de variable de supervivencia
y algunos otros puntos, está bien, cualquier otra cosa
bueno, es relación relación
relación y luego dicen que este
documento tiene como objetivo llenar este vacío
Creo que en relación no
implica necesariamente que las cosas tengan que
cerrarse en términos de lo que sea el vacío
al llenar algo Creo que creo que
el hecho de que  hablando de focalización
, pienso en el hecho de que ven que la
relación
juega un papel clave en lo que creen que
está sucediendo aquí,
um significa que  que tal vez la brecha,
um, continúa, quiero decir que están
poniendo cosas aquí para que las consideremos
y contemplemos, pero no estoy seguro de
si en realidad estamos llenando una brecha en la
que simplemente estamos entendiendo lo que hay
en esto  espacio a la
derecha en la
sección dos, por lo que al comienzo de la
sección dos, los párrafos superiores, la
intercepción, el modelado del
cuerpo, la estimación de su eficiencia, y luego
la sección 2.5 debajo del pliegue
, el resumen, por lo tanto, tanto
antes como después 2.
um 2.0
2.2
contiene mucha información estructural
sobre  los puntos clave en este documento
cualquier cosa para agregar en esta diapositiva específica
o simplemente iremos a las secciones que
aparecen en la parte inferior donde la
gente podría querer leer eso
porque creo que eso es y eso significa
que eso es controvertido pero  Creo que
es interesante, sí,
um, que el movimiento hacia
el rango de respuesta de una curva de capacidad
podría obviar potencialmente la necesidad
de un circuito o módulo neuronal dedicado
que calcule específicamente el
construcciones conductuales de los costos de recompensa,
entonces, ¿qué
significa pasar a una comprensión
no centrada en la recompensa
de la fisiología
o reinterpretar la recompensa? La
sección 2.1 introduce una
distinción que será clave en
el resto del artículo, que es la
diferencia entre dos tipos.  de
variables sensoriales viscerales interceptivas
las que representan cantidades de
recursos recursos regulados y las
que representan tasas a las que
actúan los procesos procesos controlados
los recursos regulados se mantienen estables
relativamente estables a lo largo del tiempo los ejemplos
incluyen la glucosa en sangre y la temperatura corporal central,
por
lo que es de destacar que no tienen  para ser un
recurso no renovable,
el recurso regulado es algo así como
la variable limitada en una fisiología en
un contexto de homeostasis, no es
necesariamente
no puede cambiar
instantáneamente, así que  creo que será
interesante preguntar
qué son los diferentes recursos regulados
de diferentes modalidades
y luego los procesos controlados
son las velocidades a las que
operan los procesos fisiológicos, por lo que en ese caso
sería como el tipo de relaciones de entrada y salida
de la glucosa en sangre.
sobre eso que
hablamos recientemente es cuál es la
diferencia entre gripper y gript y
pueden existir ambos a la vez
agradable
2.2 volviendo al ejemplo de DodgeBall, la
frecuencia cardíaca y la presión arterial deben
aumentar durante el ejercicio aeróbico como se
indica en el ejemplo de DodgeBall,
por lo que tiene que ser  debe haber alguna
adaptación fisiológica para comenzar a hacer ejercicio y
continuar ejercitándose
en condiciones de reposo, el barorreceptor, es
decir, el reflejo del ritmo cardíaco del receptor de presión
, normalmente contrarrestaría cualquier aumento
en la presión arterial al disminuir el ritmo
cardíaco; sin embargo, con el esfuerzo, su
presión arterial y ritmo cardíaco deben
aumentar para apoyar el  aumento necesario
en el flujo sanguíneo requerido por su
ex  ejercitar los músculos
y luego hay una discusión sobre cómo
este tipo de modulación del reflejo permite el
cambio de una función completa que
relaciona un cambio en la presión arterial con un
cambio en la frecuencia cardíaca, por
lo que esto se describe como un
enfoque de sistemas dinámicos y un modelo fisiológico
para  cómo se puede modelar la estructura causal o correlacional
de diferentes variables fisiológicas de
manera
bastante general, pero se volverá
más específico,
sí, un poco de covariación allí
y uh,
y Fisiología, y listo, vamos
bien 2.2 predecir y modelar los
rangos de procesos regulados y controlados
esto  está describiendo algunos de los
parámetros
de
la curva
el umbral y los puntos de saturación
que se derivan en parte Definir curvas que
se derivan de funciones
que los fisiólogos comúnmente usan para
modelar la conexión entre
perturbaciones y respuestas reguladoras,
generalmente denominándolas curvas de respuesta o
funciones de transferencia
y luego el término capacidad  las curvas
se utilizarán para enfatizar  e el hecho de que, si bien
tales curvas pueden cambiar con el tiempo
en cualquier instante, representan el
rango actual de recursos regulatorios limitados
disponibles para un organismo,
por lo que uno podría imaginarse como una
curva de capacidad financiera para mantener algún
Mercado en algún punto como
la profundidad
pero por
analogía
y luego esta
idea de modelar cómo responde un sistema
a las perturbaciones
no necesariamente requiere modelar el
modelo interno de ese sistema, pero a medida que
construye un mejor modelo generativo del
sistema que está siendo perturbado que los mejores
experimentos y más lejos puede  eh,
tiene una especie de perturbabilidad del
sistema que le permite acercarse a su
sistema sin una hipótesis fuerte sobre
su estructura
la curva de capacidad en el punto de la figura dos
o en la figura uno tiene la
forma matemática y luego la figura uno se muestra
junto con la ecuación uno
los parámetros son  definió la función
y es uh tomando en U mu K siendo R Big B
y combinándolos en una ecuación
la figura uno en  el eje x muestra
la presión arterial
y luego el eje y muestra el
porcentaje de activación de la línea de base del
reflejo que modula esta
variable fisiológica, por lo que en 100, cuál es la
presión arterial objetivo o algo así como lo que se
llamaría el punto de ajuste homeostático
porque  parece ser un atractor
en ese punto, la activación de la línea de base del
reflejo de barril está ocurriendo
cuando la presión arterial aumenta, luego
el reflejo de barril se activa hasta 2 veces el
umbral en 2x activación de la
línea de base y luego, a medida que la presión arterial
disminuye, el reflejo de barril nuevamente con
este sigmoide  la simetría disminuye
ese es un modelo dinámico de regulación
de la presión arterial
ecuaciones 2 3 y 4.
esbozar la forma de un modelo generativo un
procedimiento para
predecir probabilísticamente variables observadas en términos
de variables no observadas
las variables enumeradas son variables no observadas
que se muestrean de una
probabilidad A Priory  la distribución no
depende de los datos,
por lo que se refiere al uso de un
generador  modelo ive y cómo estas ecuaciones lo
constituyen
La propuesta aquí tiene una característica inusual
las ecuaciones para X la
presión arterial media y por qué la activación del reflejo de barril
como un porcentaje de la línea de base
por lo que figura 1 X e Y
o en términos de la variable cuantil U
el  La variable cuantil
representa uniformemente la relación entre la
presión arterial y la activación del reflejo de barril,
independientemente de los cambios en
el punto de operación mu de la curva de capacidad
y la ganancia K. El cuantil depende solo de
la forma funcional de la
curva de capacidad y no de los parámetros, por lo que
desglosaremos  eso un poco más técnicamente,
pero señalan que como una característica de
su modelo
aquí nuevamente está la figura uno un poco más grande
con más espacio para discutir más adelante y
aquí está la figura dos,
que es la curva de capacidad de la figura
uno en azul con una respuesta linealizada
en naranja
alrededor del punto de operación el
marcador Blue Diamond
para que
uno pueda ver esto como la máxima
pendiente positiva de esta curva sigmoidea
y  que bajo
la especificación de
que el reflejo se va a activar
de forma sigmoidal
, dependiendo de si uno está en
una parte curva hacia arriba o hacia abajo
o piensa en ello como si persiguiera la
máxima pendiente positiva,
luego persiguiera ese punto y fuera
recompensado  por movimientos hacia la máxima
maniobrabilidad y control
tendría el equivalente de seguir un
modelo homeostático donde esto es como un
atractor de punto fijo,
por lo que pone el tipo de fondo del
tazón
en esta línea naranja que se maximiza en
pendiente en lugar de que el diamante azul se
reduzca en  está a una distancia de 100.
Bien
, creo que copiamos esta
sección dos
veces. Era tan inusual que la copiamos dos veces.
y el dióxido de carbono, a
continuación nos centramos en la glucosa en sangre como un
recurso regulado con el glucagón como el
proceso controlado que permite la secreción de
glucosa en la sangre y la insulina como
el proceso de control que permite la eliminación de la
glucosa de la sangre, por lo que el reflejo del barril
era como una perilla de volumen único
o una enfermera de triaje que puede disminuir o
aumentar la respuesta única, por lo que si alguna
variable fisiológica es alta, es como
si pudiera  ser como
la regulación de la glucosa eliminada tiene múltiples
hormonas va a ser como amortiguado desde dos
lados diferentes de una manera ligeramente diferente
pero usando muchos de los mismos
formalismos y lógica
para introducir un sistema
fisiológico ligeramente diferente y más complejo
,
está bien,
la sección analiza algunos hallazgos
que los niveles de glucosa en la sangre no
se defienden activamente en un
punto fijo biológicamente codificado más de lo que la
frecuencia cardíaca es en cambio glucagón e insulina, dos
hormonas que equilibran los efectos de cada una para
llevar la glucosa en la sangre a un punto
dentro de su rango de estabilización
con la glucosa entrando en el  sangre después de que
la persona ingiere alimentos y glucosa y luego
cruza de la sangre a otros
cuerpos  tejidos para respaldar su función
cualquier cosa que agregar en esta
diapositiva no no específicamente ahora espere hasta
que lleguemos al final de la sección las
dos segundas cosas
así que aquí está la figura tres
que están escribiendo la figura tres
muestra gráficos de las funciones resultantes
de esta ecuación
aplicada a  el caso de la insulina,
que se puede interpretar como
curvas de capacidad, el sigmoide naranja es insulina,
el sigmoide azul es
glucagón, tienen diferentes niveles de hormonas en
diferentes ejes x, que es el nivel de
glucosa en la sangre, por lo que se
ve un comportamiento familiar cuando la glucosa es
alta.  entonces la secreción de insulina es alta, lo
que impulsa la absorción de glucosa
y cuando la glucosa baja, en este caso
por debajo de 2,5 o 3, entonces
se secreta glucagón para provocar que la
glucosa entre en la sangre,
está bien
, así que uno puede imaginar que el
nivel de glucosa estará oscilando  en este espacio,
pero no exactamente
establecido
en un punto fijo con un residuo
minimizado, la
sección 2.4
es donde pasan de discutir este
tipo de mo regulador  del
uh en rangos y capacidades viables
podría obviar un sistema de recompensa modular
aquí hay un argumento o apelación a la
neuroanatomía no hay un solo
sitio del cerebro que codifique específicamente el
valor de refuerzo apetitivo o aversivo es útil replantear los sistemas discretos de
recompensa y decisión como dominio
Sistemas de control alostático general
el  La generalidad del dominio de la intercepción
proporciona más apoyo teórico a
la idea de que no necesitamos
módulos mentales o conceptos de psicología de la facultad
para comprender cómo funciona un cerebro.
sistema nervioso
y un poco más sobre este tema cualquier cosa que
agregar
ahora vayamos al 37.
muy bien, las recompensas del control, así que
aquí quería resaltar dos artículos con
algunas imágenes agradables
de ambos artículos que involucran a Tobias Norville
y estos artículos se citan en el artículo.
en discusión y todos muestran
bastante interés  características de reposo, así que solo para
resaltar algunos de estos
gráficos, aquí hay movimientos dentro de un
espacio de glucosa y temperatura, por lo que la regulación de
múltiples variables fisiológicas
aquí en la parte inferior izquierda es la
integración del
punto de ajuste homeostático de intercepción y los comandos motores
relacionados con la búsqueda de alimento
aquí hay algunas
visualizaciones bayesianas con  una improbabilidad posterior anterior
y sobre esta
relación bidireccional de inferencia y un
modelo dinámico anterior la historia de dos
densidades y luego la última este es uh
otro enfoque de modelado de glucosa de temperatura corporal
que llega a esa noción que
describimos como ir al fondo  del
tazón
donde la forma de esta
servilleta
podría diseñarse, evolucionar o seleccionarse de
modo que la canica pase la mayor parte de su
tiempo en una zona determinada y esto es
solo otra forma de pensar en
este tipo de sistemas de atracción en
lugar de como huellas.  más o menos,
está bien, cualquier cosa que agregar,
bueno, creo que la sección dos básicamente
confirma que si vas a  estar
haciendo cualquier tipo de rendimiento predictivo
que tenga un elemento de
continuidad que dependa de una especie de
límites finitos reconocibles y también de la
variabilidad dentro de lo que sean esos límites
y creo que
eso habla de la idea de que hay
en un  una especie de situación de dos factores,
hay una señalización que se ve así
y señalaron un par de
ejemplos del reflejo del barril
y el glucagón
y también estaban tratando de evitar
simplificar o reducir demasiado
como intentaron  mantener
la complejidad de esos dos ejemplos
retenidos en términos de lo que estaban
tratando de sostener es algo que
nos permite comenzar a ver estas
curvas de capacidad
bien sección tres teoría de control
la lente unificadora para el control motor fisiológico
y la toma de decisiones
y luego uno  de sus resúmenes del
capítulo, esta sección
introduce Conceptos de la
teoría del control de ingeniería y luego revisa sus
aplicaciones en las Ciencias de la Vida.  Se
incluye la sección 3.1 de fisiología, la
sección 3.2 del movimiento del motor esquelético y la
sección 3.3 de toma de decisiones. La sección 3.4
conectará los estados interceptivos futuros con los
movimientos presentes.
Esclarecerá qué hace que la regulación alostática sea más
eficiente energéticamente que la regulación homeostática.
para
sugerir cómo la intercepción apoya la
alostasis,
está bien, aquí no vamos a leer
todo en la diapositiva, pero esto es de la
sección 3.1, teoría de control para
fisiología, un cuerpo confiable,
construido a partir de partes no confiables, cualquier cosa que
agregar a esto, no, la
gente solo quiere leer esto.  sí,
solo pediré que un controlador
funcione bien, debe contener algún tipo
de copia o espejo del comportamiento esperado de la planta,
que se conoce
como un modelo interno,
los teóricos del control llaman ayudar al
sistema impulsado a plantar y su
trayectoria deseada la referencia  trayectoria
y hay una discusión interesante
de este tipo de um
hilo de la teoría de control
figura cuatro
así que la figura cuatro es un diagrama de bloques funcional de un
sistema de control basado en modelos
la planta en naranja es el objeto o
sistema cuyo movimiento u otro comportamiento se
controla
el controlador púrpura envía señales
controla el bloque sólido flechas
el cambio cómo se mueve la planta  y
señala el resultado esperado predicciones
flecha amarilla continua al
estimador de estado en amarillo y así sucesivamente la gente puede
leer el resto
de estas cifras Daniel a medida que
avanzamos en las diapositivas por qué no
leo y luego puede ejecutar el cursor
sobre las diferentes partes del modelo para que las
personas puedan ver y en tiempo real
cómo se alinean las dos cosas suena
bien, lo haremos para los futuros
y esto va a
revocar o recordar
lo de nuestras discusiones anteriores en la transmisión en vivo
23 actuación hábil e
interaccionismo e instruccionismo y
cómo pensar en las plantas motoras y así sucesivamente
sección 3.2 moviendo el cuerpo la
hipótesis de control de referencia para que el
hipótesis de control de referencia las
citas proporcionadas fueron de Feldman 2015
y latash 2021
y la hipótesis de control de referencia
describe el sistema motor esquelético en
términos de una jerarquía de controladores con
controladores de nivel superior en el cerebro que
prescriben trayectorias de referencia a
los reflejos de nivel inferior en la médula
espinal estos  Luego, los reflejos comparan la
longitud real del músculo según lo señalado
por las neuronas propioceptoras aferentes con la
longitud de referencia enviada por el cerebro
y contrae el músculo para que los
dos estén de acuerdo, así que aquí está la
parte superior de la tabla de contenido del
libro de Feldman de 2015  control de referencia de la
acción y la percepción y el papel de
latash en física de la revisión de la vida 2021
con algunos gráficos sobre este tipo de
enfoque
extranjero puede comenzar con esta diapositiva en el
mundo real,
está bien, solo señalaré un par de
cosas que dicen los autores  porque ellos
no quieren ser acusados ​​de una especie de
sobreajuste aquí
inicie su control de motor  El experimento es
solo una superposición limitada con la
estructura real del control motor, por lo que
solo una superposición limitada. El experimento sobre los
comportamientos de alcance implica que un
experimentador prescriba la
tarea de alcance a los participantes. El
cerebro de los participantes no funciona específicamente para
seguir las instrucciones de un experimentador,
sino para regular su propio cuerpo.
la organización real del
sistema nervioso central ocurre mejor con una
visión de adentro hacia afuera del
movimiento de la función motora del cuerpo, es decir, las vías somatomotoras somatosas, la
regulación de la oleada del
cuerpo, por ejemplo, en el juego con el
valor Dr si inesperadamente pisa un
bloque duro o afilado o  objeto, por lo general
no te empalas a propósito a ti mismo que lo has
pisado, así que solo quería
atravesar mi pie ahora
porque podría concentrarme todavía en
estabilizar mi postura gravedad con espiral
y dolor lo sientes de manera interceptiva
y la perturbación no planificada de cualquier
el daño tisular requiere que tome una
decisión sobre qué hacer a continuación excusa  ser
usted mismo para cuidar su pie o jugar
con ese dolor
Creo que el hecho de que están tratando de
limitar lo que están diciendo es la medida
en que se puede decir que el objetivo de esto
se aplica como algo bueno
porque creo que hay un  un par de
áreas
alrededor,
entonces, ¿qué hay en esta relación entre
un sistema de comando o un sistema de control y
un sistema de demanda donde suceden cosas
como cuando su cuerpo
comienza a sufrir una hipotermia leve
y sabe que la gente sabe que
su cerebro deja de funcionar correctamente?
um, ¿cómo se diferencia entre, por
ejemplo,
um, me está dando dolor de cabeza el Slurpee y
dejas el Slurpee y dejas de
beberlo porque sabes que ese es
el efecto versus tienes las extremidades,
que no sabes, congeladas en
este punto o en  al menos, con suerte, no para
nosotros, el botón continúa moviéndose para que
no te detengas, evitas dejar de
moverte todos juntos, que es lo que
esencialmente es la muerte, así que aquí tenemos una
pregunta si o no
um w  Sin entrar en el argumento de que
porque es bastante obvio que si tu
cerebro está muerto, estás muerto, pero si tus
manos están muertas o sigues
vivo, esa clara distinción entre una
consecuencia del centro de comando y una
consecuencia del centro de demanda, ¿qué significa eso
en términos?  Está bien, entonces hay cosas que
suceden que haces automáticamente
para mantenerte con vida en algunas de
las situaciones más críticas y no es
como si
tu mano tuviera el cerebro y, sin embargo,
puede ser simplemente moviéndose. Más allá de una
cosa reflexiva.  capaz de mantenerte con
vida el tiempo suficiente hasta que alguien venga
a rescatarte como por ejemplo,
así que no sé si eso es confuso o
no, pero creo que hay una
reconciliación, pero eso continúa entre el
comando y la demanda y tal vez algo de
control.  es la capacidad de renunciar a los
tiempos ordenados para que
una nueva respuesta tome el control y lo mantenga con
vida y es posible que no necesariamente
sepa cómo hacerlo desde un
centro de comando, así que  Tendré que hablar con los
autores sobre eso porque estas son
preguntas que tengo porque tengo un
poco de experiencia fisiológica, así que me
pregunto sobre estas situaciones
extremas.  Hablaré de eso más tarde, sí, más
citas de tres tres para aquellos que
quieran hacer una captura de pantalla
hablando de ergonicidad, que también se
plantea en el apéndice B, en el que no nos
vamos a centrar,
está bien, puede leer la figura cinco y
usaré el mouse.  eh, entonces, un
diagrama de bloques funcional para un experimento
psicólogo experimental vista orientada a la tarea del
control motor el diagrama muestra una estructura lógica formal
aquí
a nivel conceptual los cuadros y
flechas no se corresponden con la anatomía
del cerebro o el sistema nervioso en contraste
con la figura cuatro  el diagrama
diferencia entre el cerebro motor esquelético
y los controladores del reflejo de estiramiento periférico
y entre los estimadores del estado sensorial del
cerebro y la periferia  todos los
órganos de los sentidos superficies sensoriales superficies sensoriales
el diagrama muestra una
perspectiva de ingeniería
importante tener en cuenta que en un
experimento de psicología en el que el experimentador
prescribe una tarea de comportamiento a los
participantes, por lo que hay una externalidad
y el cerebro del participante actúa como un
sistema de control para lograr el comportamiento
los
sistemas de Comportamiento prescritos que mantienen el cuerpo, por lo tanto,
sirven a los sistemas que mueven el cuerpo,
que a su vez sirven a un Comportamiento prescrito,
así que nuevamente concéntrese en lo
prescriptivo, la externalidad, la
información que llega en
todas las
funciones correctas de la computadora portátil, sí, el siguiente
diagrama de bloques funcional para una
vista teórica de control.  de alostasis en contraste
con la figura cinco, este diagrama muestra un
sistema de control de circuito cerrado diseñado para
la regulación autónoma del cuerpo y
los comportamientos de tarea deseados del experimentador
reemplazado con o por perdón el
estimador de capacidad alostática
que envía predicciones de curvas de capacidad
que ya hemos visto para
el receptáculo interior  Estimador de estado dinámico
y recibe errores de predicción con los
que actualizar sus
estimaciones Las estimaciones actualizadas se emiten como una
señal de referencia para el
controlador del motor visitante Este diagrama muestra una
estructura lógica formal Un nivel conceptual La
hipótesis representada está restringida por
las estructuras anatómicas inferidas en
Bear 2017  pero los recuadros y las flechas
no mapean
una repetición, no mapean uno a uno en la
anatomía del cerebro o del sistema nervioso,
muy bien,
solo para resaltar la diferencia aquí,
la izquierda es casi como un
instructivo
Arreglos y así es como el
psicólogo experimental  piensa en
esta tarea, que es como si escribiésemos
las instrucciones, el pseudocódigo para la
tarea, mantenga su ritmo cardíaco dentro de este
rango
y luego tome algunas decisiones
con el sistema motor Skeletor, ya sea
capaz de acción consciente
y estiramiento
o más, uh, subconsciente
y luego actúe a través de  fisiología en
el cuerpo o en el mundo externo que
intercepti  El estimador de cinco estados se
alinea con la
implementación deseada de la decisión motora esquelética
,
en contraste, el papel de las instrucciones de la tarea
, por así decirlo, se sustituye
en esta vista teórica de control
con el estimador de capacidad alostática
como el imperativo y que se alimenta a
través de un conjunto muy similar.  en el
lado derecho, pero aquí tenemos el
controlador de decisión de motor de
vísceras en contraste con un
controlador de decisión de motor escalar porque está más
enfocado en
elegir el botón izquierdo o el
botón derecho y la figura seis se enfoca más en
el tipo de barril
vista de la teoría del control reflejo, pero eso también
generaliza Más allá,
está bien, creo que es solo otra vista
sección cuatro alostasis como
seguimiento de la trayectoria control estocástico óptimo
esta sección describirá nuestro
modelo formal de toma de decisiones
alostática la ruta alostática control integral
modelo
apic apic tiene una idea simple en su  Los conceptos básicos, al
igual que los perceptuales, sirven como
modelos internos del cuerpo.  Los conceptos de acción de las superficies sensoriales de dy
también sirven como
modelos internos de comportamientos potenciales y sus
resultados predichos.
agregue
no vamos allí bien 4.1
transformando las curvas de capacidad en
funciones objetivo
ya que cualquier curva de capacidad dada, como
la 1 y la figura 1 anterior,
que es un valor máximo en el eje vertical,
se puede dividir por su valor máximo y
para normalizarlo al rango  entre 0
y 1. una vez normalizado de esta manera,
puede interpretarse como una función de
distribución acumulativa de la teoría de la probabilidad. De hecho,
esto es precisamente lo que
hicieron srinivasan Laughlin y
dubs para interpretar el disparo de las
neuronas retinianas y las moscas como una forma de
codificación predictiva.  en la figura uno,
la derivada de una función de
distribución acumulativa CDF produce un
probabi  función de densidad de densidad PDF por
lo que la derivada de una CDF da una PDF
esta es la forma más familiar de
representar una distribución de probabilidad
donde la altura en el eje vertical
corresponde a la probabilidad en la PDF
pero para una PDF derivada de una
curva de capacidad representa la capacidad de
respuesta relativa  a la perturbación,
llamaremos a dicha distribución una distribución de referencia,
por
lo que esta es una transformación de
distribuciones estadísticas entre
PDF, que es la función de densidad de probabilidad
y la función de distribución acumulativa CDF.
Puede ser muy familiar para algunos,
puede ser totalmente nuevo para algunos, así que
todo está bien.  esperemos que esto sea útil
para considerar la relación entre los
dos,
así que aquí, a la izquierda de estas tres
imágenes, el PDF, que es la forma más
familiar de representar una
distribución de probabilidad, diríamos que
esta es una distribución uniforme, hay
una posibilidad entre seis de obtener  cada
resultado de un dado de seis caras
o en una situación de curva de campana de Gauss que
h ambas
imágenes del medio y la derecha muestran que
la PDF de la curva de campana es la
curva de campana por lo que la PDF es la más
familiar la distribución uniforme es como una
línea plana en la PDF la curva de campana es
como una curva de campana en la PDF
pero dado que conoce los valores máximo y
mínimo,
aunque solo asintóticamente,
entonces puede hacer una función de
distribución acumulativa que comienza
básicamente tan bajo como la función puede ser
el soporte para esa distribución y
solo se acumula acumulativamente,
por lo que es útil para responder a la
pregunta ¿qué es?  la probabilidad de
obtener un cuatro o tres o dos o uno
que sea dos tercios o cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener una puntuación z por
debajo de dos como dos desviaciones estándar
positivas qué fracción de la curva está
por debajo de esa puntuación z en el PDF  y eso
se puede abordar rápidamente con solo
buscar un punto en este
CDF, resulta que esa relación
entre el PDF y el CDF, que es
más familiar para volver a lanzar un
dado o evaluar como  la altura en un
salón de clases
se puede usar
en la curva de capacidad discutida anteriormente
para pasar a una distribución que, cuando se
maximiza, está en este
punto de control Máximo,
por lo que aquí la CDF de la figura 2
obtiene la derivada y luego se convierte en
PDF con este tipo de negativo
la forma de la curva y eso es algo de lo que
se insinuaba con esta
línea naranja maximizada. La línea naranja
maximizada
es el punto más alto de esta
curva de campana, pero no es un velcro clásico,
pero es una montaña, es un
pico que puedes saber de qué lado.  está
activado y, por lo tanto, se optimiza con bastante facilidad
hacia
um
por conveniencia analítica, tomamos la
práctica de tedorov 2006 de usar una
densidad logarítmica el logaritmo de un PDF como una
función objetiva en lugar del PDF en
sí mismo,
el punto operativo luego continúa
apareciendo como máximo local  mientras que la ganancia
determina el costo del movimiento lejos
del punto de operación y el valor
del movimiento hacia él la figura 8 muestra
la función objetivo log de  nsidad
correspondiente a la
curva de capacidad del reflejo de barril original La
figura 9 aclara aún más la
relación entre las diversas formas
de la curva de capacidad al mostrar las tres una al
lado de la otra, por lo que esta es una
figura realmente agradable en la parte superior izquierda de la
figura es la figura uno con el reflejo
que se marca hacia arriba o hacia abajo para
regular la presión arterial
que, cuando se interpreta como un CDF,
puede dar como resultado un PDF
y ese es un pico único que puede
maximizar en
lugar de intentar calcular un
residual.
La forma de esta curva se vuelve un poco
más agradable para optimizar computacionalmente.
cuando lo haces para que sea como un
tazón más suave en
lugar de este tipo de forma de
embudo
invertido, solo
podemos entrar en más detalles por qué creo
que será genial por qué este paso de registro
importa o importa, pero basta con
decir  que este es el gran movimiento que
te permite convertir el
acto de malabarismo sigmoideo en
la
tabla de escalar una montaña uno resume una tabla clave
uno resume algunas anotaciones clave
No afirmamos que nuestro modelo gráfico
capture con precisión la anatomía del
cerebro. Captura
el control sensoriomotor basado en referencias en una jerarquía
de escalas de tiempo. Una característica única compartida
con un cerebro.
Variables
en una tabla.
Ecuaciones cinco y seis sobre la
tasa de captura instantánea
discútalo en el punto 1.2,
sección 4.2, también será bueno discutir
si es un forrajeo óptimo. La teoría sugiere una
forma funcional para el control
alostático. ¿Desea agregar algo por adelantado
sobre el forrajeo óptimo
? Quiero hablar
con los autores.  sobre qué
significa
eso, eso será genial, muy bien ecuación
ocho
Tasa de captura global
sección 4.3 retroalimentación o
control de avance con conceptos de acción generativa
así que aquí hay algunos formalismos más y esto
no está dentro del
marco del psicólogo experimental
sino del marco teórico de control
con  el
estimador de capacidad alostática en la
sección izquierda 4.3
ecuación 10 ecuación 11.
más variables
stoc  SOC de control óptimo hastic que se
mencionó anteriormente en la
ecuación 12.
Figura 10. Será bueno
analizar un modelo generativo jerárquico que
capture múltiples escalas de tiempo y
distribuciones de referencia en cada nivel
sin abordar cuestiones empíricas
sobre jerarquías neuronales aquí empleamos
un modelo con L igual  cuatro modelos para que
coincidan con la figura
seis, define lo que significan algunos de estos nodos,
pero el eje y aumenta la escala de tiempo,
por lo que quizás las cosas sean más lentas más arriba y
luego a la derecha está el paso del tiempo,
entonces, ¿en qué te hace pensar esto
o qué es?  como una forma en que podemos abordar
la interpretación de esto,
bueno, no estoy tratando de ser un Apple inteligente,
pero me parece interesante que L4
te brinde bastante
información, quiero decir que
tal vez haya y ellos hablan sobre el  el hecho de
que hay más de cuatro niveles,
pero quieren centrarse en esos para mí, quiero
decir, a dónde va mi cerebro está bien
, tenemos el agua, tenemos la levadura
, tenemos el lúpulo,  obtuve los granos y
eso puede crear
bastante el producto, por lo que puede pasar
que puede agregar jugo o lo que sea,
pero obtuvo los cuatro ingredientes básicos, así que
ahora, moviéndose en el tiempo, ¿qué
permite eso? De nuevo, sería bueno para ellos.  para
separar eso porque
creo que incluso en esto hay suficiente
para
resolver muchas cosas
correctamente 4.4 control de retroalimentación con
acción generativa Conceptos todavía
hay ecuación 13 ecuación 14. y luego una
buena cita lectores familiarizados con el
procesamiento predictivo
y activo  la inferencia reconocerá la
forma de la ecuación anterior 14.
como una energía libre negativa o
un límite inferior variacional para la discusión vea algunas
citas ya que los objetivos generalmente se
pueden escribir e interpretar de
varias maneras equivalentes Cada una de las cuales
puede venir con sus propias intuiciones
Hay argumentos  para la eficiencia computacional y
termodinámica de minimizar
esta Divergencia específica en el curso
del procesamiento neuronal pero hasta la fecha el
avai  La evidencia lable no descarta
otras divergencias de información más complejas
para penalizar la
corrección de retroalimentación de los movimientos,
por lo que es bastante interesante cómo existen diferentes
límites
inferiores, límites inferiores variacionales, energías libres negativas
, como si hubiera
energía libre esperada y luego energía libre
del futuro esperado y
todo  estas variantes y luego cada una de esas
energías se pueden descomponer de manera diferente
como la ecuación 2.6 en el libro de texto,
por lo que es
interesante ver cómo, en primer lugar,
cómo convergieron en este tipo de abundancia
y
por qué debería tener tanta resonancia
con el principio de energía libre
y qué significa  eso significa
y luego, ¿cómo pueden las diferentes particiones
de estos límites de energía ayudarnos a
pensar en los sistemas que sobreviven
? Simplemente agregaré aquí, Daniel, que vamos
a llegar a estas cosas, pero hasta
este punto del documento, creo que tenía un
poco  de familiaridad y realmente no
luché con el tipo de bloqueo en el
que estaban pasando por esto,
pero  tan pronto como llegamos a las ecuaciones 13
y el salto a las ecuaciones 15 y 16,
alguien más brillante que
yo tendrá que ser capaz de explicar ese
salto en términos muy simples porque
aunque lo he leído varias
veces  Todavía no estoy exactamente seguro de cómo
funciona, así que nuevamente los autores realmente
querrán traer
sus guantes más suaves porque necesito mi
computadora de mano,
sí, de acuerdo.
fantasía
J
ecuación 14.
y la expresión analítica para el
controlador de retroalimentación óptimo solo
ecuación 15 en la ecuación de Bellman
ecuación 12 daría como resultado la
ecuación 16. aprendamos qué es sí
ahora el término recursivo intratable en
la ecuación es
Etc
encontrar una manera de reemplazar esto  El término
producirá un problema más tratable computacionalmente. El
término de divergencia de información en fantasía
J proporciona tal manera, ya que se
puede escribir precisamente como
la diferencia.  entre el
máximo duro intratable bajo la estrella Q estrella sub Phi
y el máximo suave más manejable
bajo la acción planificada previamente Concepto en
símbolos ecuación 17. bastante interesante
está bien
um s ecuación 17 a 21
luego la sección final sección cinco
discusión
tal vez puedas ayudarme  hoy tenemos del 13
al 17 y luego del 18 al 19 y al 20 una
manera de poder juntar
algunos de los formalismos libres de escala
con la escala específica o
escala amigable
um detalles en particular cuando lees
esto es lo que los viste  tratando de
aclarar
esa es una gran
pregunta
y entonces hablas de global
y creo que tienen que ser capaces de
explicarlo y creo que sí, pero de
nuevo, estoy,
estoy, de repente las cosas se fueron
a la zanja para mí.
esto es lo que me atrevería a
aventurar
en la primera sección,
hay un contraste de
homeostasis con alostasis
y sobre cómo los sistemas de recompensa ya
no son necesarios bajo ciertos
modelos distribuidos de neuroanatomía cerebral
y una función
por lo tanto, creo que los siguientes
formalismos sustituyen el objetivo aumentado
en un
marco de optimización y optimización
como la ecuación de Bellman, que a menudo se
usa para maximizar la recompensa.
dependiendo de la cantidad de recompensa que acumulen, está bien
y luego la curiosidad, etc., será
valiosa en la medida en el tiempo
Horizon que consideré
que facilita la recompensa en términos de
elevación,
mientras que aquí estamos viendo el movimiento
hacia eso como la
maximización de la maniobrabilidad óptima
con la relación pdfcdf
como en lugar de tratar de reducir la
Divergencia al punto medio de la
CDF, maximiza su capacidad
de respuesta en términos de maximizar el PDF de registro, está bien,
entonces creo que esa es la
función de recompensa um aumentada
que es manejable
y luego queda algo de trabajo para
especificar esa función y cómo  se comporta
tal vez
bien
entonces la sección cinco discusión
intercepción estabiliza la acción y
construye todo  referencias lostatic la
gente puede mirar las citas cualquier cosa
para resumir aquí
no está bien 5.1 ver el cerebro como un
controlador óptimo
alostático el modelo apic de control integral de camino alostático
en la sección 4 implica una serie
de hipótesis específicas más allá de las
genéricas al control óptimo estocástico
hay algo de discusión  de
opciones de modelado compartidas con modelos de inferencia activa
tal vez suficiente para que apic se considere
una especie de modelo de inferencia activa
y luego algunas otras características que se
comparten con modelos de inferencia activa en
sentido estricto si es que existe
y también esfuerzos de modelado relacionados
algo para agregar
no  no, lo deletrean bastante claramente
aquí solo quieres leer esto
bien el 5.1 proporciona algunas predicciones
y algunos contrastes con el modelo apic
5.2
el cuerpo y el cerebro a través de la lente
de la teoría del control la
figura seis muestra cómo los datos de los sentidos
viscerales ascienden en efecto  para convertirse en
errores de predicción interceptiva aferente X
¿quieres explicar br  iefly lo que significa un afluente X
porque la gente podría explicar
eso en el glosario, pero es
básicamente una señal aparente en una
señal operativa, hay un poco de
recursión
allí, quieres agregar algo a eso,
um
,
veo la distinción
solo para resaltar qué aferente  es
aferente es conductor o conducido
hacia adentro o hacia algo para los
nervios el sistema nervioso central para los
vasos sanguíneos el órgano suministrado correctamente
y um,
¿cómo distinguiría los esfuerzos exactos?
es lo que saqué de que la
acumulación de esas señales aparentes es
interesante
. Creo que te equivocas. Eso es lo que saqué.
Cinco tres interceptación y curvas de capacidad.
las respuestas se reservan
para los estímulos más sorprendentes
alguna predicción  s y sugerencias de
Barrett 2017
y hallazgos de dwark en 2013 ciertos
interceptores periféricos y humanos
reducen su tasa de disparo operante a cero
bajo un estímulo constante,
por lo que es algo interesante como si no hubiera
cambios
, no me lo digas y eso debería
ser barato bajo  un modelo en el que
algo cambia con menos frecuencia,
um, y hay algunas
hipótesis más que hemos planteado como hipótesis de que los
aumentos en dicha capacidad de respuesta, que
es el imperativo en este modelo apic,
podrían funcionar como recompensas que
refuerzan positivamente las trayectorias de comportamiento,
mientras que las disminuciones en la capacidad de respuesta podrían
funcionar como costos negativamente  reforzar
las trayectorias de comportamiento, de
modo que mantener las opciones abiertas durante el
tiempo infinito Horizon se vuelve equivalente
a mantener el negocio flotante o
mantener la fisiología limitada,
sí,
la continuidad externa en
lugar de simplemente maximizar la
cantidad de USD o calorías,
sino tener una sorpresa reducida o
limitada sobre un rango y una
trayectoria y  una estrategia
no  en este modelo como se indica aquí
para generar que
5.3 intercepción y curvas de capacidad
más
5.4 conclusiones finalmente volvemos al
jugador aficionado de dodgeball
la hormiga madura sí y
um algunos resúmenes del modelo apic
y sugerencias sobre su compatibilidad
con una hipótesis de control referente
y algunos de  su manejabilidad,
esa es la discusión, luego el apéndice B, el
aire acondicionado del
que hemos hablado antes, pero
es un tema interesante, por lo que solo para
saltear estos apéndices solo
discutiéndolos con los autores, esperamos que luego, eh,
algunas ecuaciones más en la ecuación B
formulando prescripción y  el control
aeróbico conduce al
principio de energía libre fep
más del apéndice B apéndice C apic
derivación del modelo detalles
ecuaciones
C 0.1.2 derivación completa de la función de valor óptimo
y dinámica de transición más
ecuaciones
la forma integral de trayectoria para el valor la
función de deseabilidad da su nombre a
la técnica  de control integral de trayectoria
y así sucesivamente una especie de nota de cierre
que  me preguntaba cómo se conecta esto con la
mecánica bayesiana
y con la formulación de la ruta, la
más a la derecha de las tres
caras de la mecánica bayesiana,
y cómo es posible que surgieran algunas características similares desde
un punto de partida bastante diferente
y con diferentes
enfoques y restricciones
y se destacaran
en apic
que también se resaltan y son relevantes
para la mecánica bayesiana en la
formalización de la ruta y tal vez haya
una especie de diagrama de Venn sin mapear
allí y algunas similitudes y
diferencias La
proximidad a la última transmisión en vivo,
ya sea por accidente o por intención,
hace que
la forma en que miras sea um  este documento,
um
interesante, solo diré que
sí, de
acuerdo,
cualquier cosa con la que quieras
cerrar
, creo que la idea de poder
ver un mod en el modelado y el
modelado interno y una especie de coordinación de
eso de nuevo como un mínimo de dos  otro como
un ejercicio de gestión o minimización de riesgos,
por lo tanto, una estrategia limitante
o como una generación de opciones
Sería
muy interesante hablar con los
autores sobre una estrategia de erating o expansión porque, de nuevo, no
puedo, realmente no puedo descifrar si
el modelo ápico funciona o no en ambos dominios
hasta que supere el salto entre el
formalismo 13
y todos  el camino hasta 17 18 19 a 20.
pero quiero decir con una explicación de eso
y uh y un empujón suave sería
interesante descubrir cómo
funciona eso cuando esas cosas parecen
ser nosotros como
entidades fisiológicas  son capaces de hacer malabarismos tanto con la
gestión de riesgos como con la
expansión de la opción del generador de opciones, por lo que estoy
realmente muy entusiasmado con eso
desde un
aquí es lo que siento, ¿cómo debo
leer eso en términos de lo que puedo, qué tan
lejos puedo hacer mi  siguiente apuesta
desde una perspectiva alostática Creo
que es
realmente emocionante si, como
dije, puedo tener
una mejor idea de cómo funciona ese salto en
su modelo
[Música]
sí, definitivamente estoy interesado en ese
horizonte de tiempo infinito y esa mentalidad
de como
w  esa es la mejor
decisión fisiológica sobre el Horizonte infinito,
espera, esa es una gran pregunta y sí,
el Eterno ahora
la presencia
y luego, um, también un poco más
mundano, como qué tipo de datos
son relevantes para este tipo de modelo, ¿
son datos que ya existen?
gente, ¿
es algo en lo que puede
extrapolar mucho de un conjunto de datos dispersos
o necesita un montón de replicaciones para
obtener una buena confianza estadística en el
parámetro del modelo y extraer hallazgos
que no son triviales? ¿
Dónde
se usa esta tecnología o enfoque?  o ¿
dónde podría usarse? Hay
muchas cosas de las que será interesante
hablar.
Bueno,
gracias por toda la preparación y la
ayuda en este Dean, nos vemos en el
punto uno y más allá, está bien,
amigo, cuídate, adiós.